[Music]
good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight if you were on social
media over the weekend you probably saw
this video it was shot Friday afternoon
on the steps of the Lincoln Memorial it
seemed to show a group of teenage boys
taunting an elderly American Indian man
who was holding a drum the young man had
come to Washington from a Catholic
school in Kentucky to demonstrate in the
March for Life some of the more make
America great again hats they seem
menacing within hours the video is being
replayed by virtually every news outlet
in America here's what you may have seen
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
well the American Indian man with the
drum he just saw is called Nathan
Phillips and he described the young men
he encountered the ones in the hats as
aggressive and threatening essentially
shock troops for Donald Trump watch dem
sayings build that wall
[Music]
this is indigenous lands
[Music]
well it's hard to remember the last time
the great American meme machine produced
a clearer contrast between good and evil
it was essentially an entire morality
play shrunk down to four minutes for
Facebook on the one side you had a noble
tribal elder weather-beaten calm and
wise he liked a living icon you could
imagine a single tear sliding slowly
down his cheek at the senselessness of
it all and on the other side you had a
pack of heedless sneering young men from
the south drunk on racism and white
privilege the irony was overwhelming the
indigenous man's land had been stolen by
the ancestors of these boys and maggots
and yet they dared to lecture him about
walls designed to keep people who look
very much like him out of what they were
calling their country
it was infuriating to a lot of people at
the same time it was also strangely
comforting to those who watched it from
Brooklyn in LA the people who run this
country have long suspected that Middle
America is a hive of nativist bigotry
and now they had proof of that it was a
cause for a celebration of outrage
because there's nothing quite as
satisfying as having your own biases
confirmed but did the video really
describe what happened that should have
been the first question that journalists
asked checking facts and adding context
is what journalists are paid to do it's
in the first line of the job description
and yet amazingly almost nobody in the
American media did that and that's a
shame because there was a lot to check
the full video of what happened on
Friday in Washington is well over an
hour long the four minutes that made
Twitter don't tell the story but instead
distort the story a longer look shows
that the boys from Covington Catholic in
Kentucky were not a roving mob looking
for a fight they were in fact and it
shows it on the tape standing in place
waiting to be picked up by a bus as they
waited they're members of a group called
the black Hebrew Israelites that's a
black supremacist organization began
taunting them with racial epithets and
then Nathan Phillips the now famous
American Indian activist approach them
pounding on his drum now the footage
seems to suggest that the boys were
unsure of whether Phillips was hostile
or taking their side against the black
Hebrew Israelites
but in any case there is no evidence at
all that anybody said build a wall
here's a selection of what didn't make
social media so what really happened on
Friday well you can watch for yourself
and decide there's plenty of video out
there of it and some of it is
fascinating and revealing but what we
know for certain at this point is that
our cultural leaders are in effect
bigots and they understand the reality
on the basis of stereotypes when the
facts don't conform to what they think
they know they ignore the facts they see
this country not as a group of people or
of citizens but as a collection of
groups and some of those groups they are
convinced are morally inferior to other
groups they know that's true they say it
out loud and that belief shapes almost
all of their perceptions of the world
it's not surprising then that when a
group of pro-life Catholic kids who look
like lacrosse players and live in
Kentucky are accused of wrongdoing the
media don't pause for a moment before
casting judgment Maggie Haberman of the
New York Times suggested the boys needed
to be expelled from school and a navarro
of CNN called the boys racists and
[ __ ] and then went after their
teachers and their parents others called
for violence against them CNN legal
analyst Bakari sellers suggested one of
the boys should be quote punched in the
face former CNN contributor reza aslan
agreed a son asked on Twitter this have
you ever seen a more punchable face than
this kid's longtime CNN contributor
Kathy Griffin's seemed to encourage a
mob to rise up and hurt these boys quote
name these kids I want names shame them
if you think these efforts wouldn't
Ducks you in a heartbeat think again
then she repeated her demand again later
quote names please and stories from
people who can identify them and vouch
for their identity thank you
Hollywood film producer Jack
Morrisey tweeted that he wanted the boys
killed quote Magga kids go screaming
hats first into the wood chipper and
then he paired that with a graphic photo
actor Patton Oswald linked to personal
information about one of the boys in
case anyone wanted to get started on
that project meanwhile Twitter which
claims to have a policy against
encouraging violence stood by silently
as all of this happened but in case you
think the response was entirely from the
left he should know that the abuse was
bipartisan it wasn't just left versus
right
he was the people in power attacking
those below them as a group plenty of
Republicans in Washington were happy to
savage the Covington kids probably to
inoculate themselves from charges of
improper thought bill kristol asked his
Twitter followers to consider a quote
the contrast between the calm dignity
and quiet strength of mr. Phillips and
the behavior of Magha brats who have
absorbed the spirit of trumpism and then
when the actual facts emerged crystal
quietly deleted his tweet he never
apologized of course he hasn't
apologized for the Iraq war either
there's no need people keep giving him
money National Review meanwhile ran a
story entitled the Covington students
might as well have spit on the cross
that story has since been pulled - but
not before the author admitted he never
even bothered to watch all of the videos
he knew what he knew and that was enough
what's so interesting about the coverage
of Friday's videos was how much of it
mentioned something called privilege
Alex Krantz who's an editor in his moto
for example wrote this from elementary
school through college I went to school
with sheltered upper middle class white
boys who could devastate with a smirk a
facial gesture that weaponized their
privilege infuriatingly you can't fight
that effing smirk with a punch or words
we saw that as trumps worked his way
through the election and will see it as
that boy from Kentucky's friends family
and school protect him i effing hate
that smirk it says I'm richer I'm white
and I'm a guy what's so fascinating
about all of these attacks is how
inverted they are these are high school
kids from Kentucky do they really have
more privileged than Alec's Kranz from
Gizmodo probably not in fact probably
much less they're far less privileged in
fact than virtually everyone who was
called for them to be destroyed on the
basis they have too much
privileged consider Kara Swisher for
example she's an opinion column as to
the New York Times
Swisher went to Princeton day school and
then Georgetown then got a graduate
degree at Columbia
she has become rich and famous in the
mean time by toadying for billionaire
tech CEO she's their handmaiden nobody
considers her very talented and if she
somehow highly influential in our
society is she more privileged than the
boys of Covington Catholic in Kentucky
of course she is maybe that's why she
feels the needs to call the Nazis which
she did repeatedly so what's actually
going on here well it's not really about
race in fact most of the stories about
race aren't really about race and this
is no different this story is about the
people in power protecting their power
and justifying their power by destroying
and mocking those who are weaker than
they are
why simple our leaders have not improved
the lives of most people in America they
can't admit that because it would
discredit them so instead they attack
the very people they have failed
the problem they'll tell us with
Kentucky isn't that bad policies have
hurt the people who live there is that
the people who live there are amoral
because they're bigots they deserve
their poverty in their opioid addiction
they deserve to die younger that's what
our leaders tell themselves and now
that's what they're telling us just
remember they're lying when they do